yes bernie sanders endorsed Hillary
Clinton he even told the supporters to
vote for her so why are some Bernie
supporters still choosing the flat out
reject Clinton and turned to the Green
Party instead people are hungry for more
choices but the American political
system excels at suppressing the voices
of opposition Green Party presumptive
nominee Jill Stein is urging voters who
are disenchanted with the establishment
parties to go third party but some say
of what for Stein would basically be a
vote for Trump sign is currently polling
at only around three percent and the
Green Party in general says it has only
about 130 elected officials across the
country all at the local level so what
is it about Jill Stein and the Green
Party that's attracting Democratic
voters anyway dr. Cornel West called
signed the only progressive woman in
this race sign is definitely progressive
she's a harvard-educated doctor turned
activist and her party holds a lot of
the same values Bernie Sanders does
eliminating public college tuition
combating climate change and cutting
back on corporate influence and while
Clinton also supports some of these
platforms Stein takes them a step
further
whereas Clinton has pledged to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by 80% by 2050
sign is calling for 100 percent
renewable energy by 2030 but many
experts say that's unrealistic Stein
also says she'll end fracking while
Clinton has a history of backing it on
health care Stein promises to expand
Medicare to everyone so citizens tax
dollars would pay for their health care
whereas Clinton has pledged to continue
to expand the affordable care act with
the hope of someday creating a public
option Stein also said she'd cut
military spending by at least half and
closed the more than 700 US bases
overseas Clinton doesn't have any plans
to cut military budgets as far as
education goes Stein wants to eliminate
public college tuition and abolish
student debt altogether while Clinton
says she wants to make College free for
students and families earning up to
$125,000 a year by 2021 science
platforms align with many Democrats
views and to top it off she says she
hasn't taken any corporate lobbyists or
super PAC money but Stein's experience
tics is limited to serving as a City
Councilmember for a small town in
Massachusetts which is still more than
this guy can say and the last time a
Green Party nominee had any influence in
the presidential race it's widely argued
that he swung the election in favor of
Republican nominee George W Bush the
some say Al Gore would have lost anyway
Justin may not realistically get the
support she needs to be a major
contender for this election even the
other third party candidate libertarian
Gary Johnson is polling higher than her
so what will it actually take to go
beyond our two-party system